a Zelda game without bosses is like rice
without any Curry like yeah you could
just eat the rice it might even taste
good fried or with a little salt but
where's the doll where's the paneer
where's the chicken tikka bosses are
what make Zelda games feel unique and
interesting and Skyward Sword has no
lack of interesting and unique bosses
indeed so buckle up and get ready
because to continue my series explaining
every boss in every Zelda game we're
gonna dive deep into the stories and
lore behind every single boss in the
first game on the timeline The Legend of
Zelda Skyward Sword and spoiler alert
obviously the first genre or grouping of
bosses will cover would be those that
are the natural enemies of the game what
I mean by that is bosses or beings that
may have not been affected by demise's
malice or girham's personality or at
least the ones that are not confirmed to
have been affected speaking of enemies
that aren't confirmed to be affected
there are a few bosses that fit this
criteria that aren't really bosses but
do serve as many bosses the first time
they're encountered due to the fact that
they are a bit tougher than your average
macablin which which is a trend that
happens with these same enemies in a lot
of Zelda games actually first up is the
Liz alfos which is a monster that may or
may not have been entirely created out
of the evil power and Malice of demise
many years ago when he initially created
his armies to battle against hylia and
the forces of light the reason I say
they may have been created by demise is
because Phi tells us directly that
demise is the source of all monsters
however there are some monsters which
I'll go over that didn't stem from
demise so it's also possible that things
like the Liz all foes are naturally
occurring species in the land of Hyrule
but I digress the next boss that may
have not originated from demise's power
is the mulderrack which is a giant
armor-clad thousand-year-old scorpion
monster with a large singular eye well
actually three eyes with two in its
claws and one in the middle which is
reminiscent of Goma which is another
reappearing boss of the Zelda franchise
that appears differently each time but
every time being some sort of an
arachnid monster that always features a
singular main eye for link to normally
shoot at the mold Iraq is actually just
an aged version of the much more
abundant and much more Tiny araka
Monsters which are very similar to just
real life scorpions with one eye we
don't have any specific reason to
believe these monsters were created by
demise except for the fact that they
disappear in a puff of purple smoke when
they die but you know it could go either
way next up is a boss that would
actually be difficult to connect to
demise and that is the 100 robotic
artificial life form known as the
ld-002g servo or as I like to call him
yarg the robot pirate beep boop Servo is
a member of the ancient robot race
encountered on the sand ship which used
to be just a regular ship before the sea
became sand also fun fact the LD in all
these robots name stands for lineru
Desert which makes sense until you
remember that when they were created it
was an ocean not a desert but we just
won't dwell on that for too long we
actually know a little bit about servo's
backstory too according to a single word
from fee it's possible that Servo used
to be a member of the crew of the ship
led by
ld-301n Skipper and that serva then led
a few of other crew members in a mutiny
against Skipper and his loyal crew but I
know what you're thinking how could
robots command a ship and even Mutiny
against each other where do they come
from well and this is just a theory of
course but in my opinion the ancient
robots were created by an ancient race
of people that are closely associated
with hylia and nehru and technology and
also the color blue you know the Chica
we know they existed in the ancient
times of Skyward Sword because impa
comes from the past I think it's pretty
plausible that the sheikah were mining
time shift stones in order to create the
Gate of time under order of the goddess
hylia who is credited with the creation
of the Gate of time and also possibly
being the goddess of time itself but hey
that's a whole other Theory the time
shift stones that are cut and processed
even have an ancient version of the
sheika eye symbol present on them I
think that the ancient robots were most
likely created either by the sheikah or
by hylia herself in order to assist in
mining time shift Stones perhaps even in
order to find all of the powerful
resource there is to find in the world
before it can fall into the clutches of
demise because if demise were to also
harm is the ability to travel through
time at will that could be problematic
this is why the ancient robots created
ancient ships in the shipyard in order
to travel far across the ancient sea and
scour the region for time shift ore led
by one ld-301 model in particular
Skipper then one day there was a sea
Squall and conveniently that was also
the day that Servo decided to mute knee
and take over this ship there's also an
improved version of the
ld-002g servo known as The
ld-003d Dread fuse who appears much
later in the game in the sky keep which
is a Shifty dungeon created by hylia in
order to keep the Triforce hidden from
the world and also helps to prove that
the ancient robots were in fact created
by hylia either directly or indirectly
since everything inside the sky keep
must have been placed thereby highly as
a test for the hero this is also another
reason to potentially believe that not
all monsters were created by demise
since there are the goblins and moblins
and keys and others located inside the
key but anyway moving on the next boss
in this section would be the underground
crawling insects known as mole dorms
that make multiple appearances in this
game and in other games in the franchise
I personally believe that these monsters
are just naturally occurring large
insect Wildlife that just so happens to
be aggressive towards link just like
most of their other appearances their
elongated segmented worm-like
centipede-like monsters that are clad in
armor everywhere but for their tails
except for in Twilight Princess when
they're just little jumpy worms the
final boss for this first section of the
video would be the infamously
intimidating Abyssal Leviathan known as
tentalis I had to research long and hard
to get the backs around this one but I'm
pretty sure you're gonna enjoy it you
see long ago in a galaxy far far away
there was a little one-eyed monster
known as Michael Wazowski over a long
painstaking ordeal Mike was finally able
to marry his longtime girlfriend Celia
May together they had a child that
shared characteristics from both of them
and was born with a single eye and
snake-like hair tendrils
um in all seriousness though this boss
out of pretty much every Zelda boss in
the history of Zelda bosses is probably
one of the worst designs for an Abyssal
Leviathan that I've ever seen and yes
its design looks like something out of
Monsters Incorporated you're really
similar in fact like like seriously does
Disney know about this do they need to
get involved but appearances aside there
are a couple things that we can guess
about its background which otherwise is
completely devoid of any and all details
see when you actually face the giant
tentacle monster it's in the distant
past as proven by all the water around
the boat and also the fact that the boat
doesn't look like a piece of garbage and
also when you talk to your flying blue
computer companion about tentalis she
confirms that it was a tyrant of the
ancient Seas now this is particularly
interesting because we also know that
where tintelis is a storm or sea Squall
is sure to follow as proven by the storm
or sea Squall that we can see here while
fighting it and while we don't have any
other confirmed records of an ancient
sea monster plaguing anybody in the game
we do have a record of an ancient
terrible sea Squall that happened on the
same day that the Mutiny occurred aboard
Skipper's ship and personally I don't
find that a coincidence so on the one
hand it could could be that demise or
girohim was responsible for creating
tintalus and making tintalus make storms
that led to mutinies or on the other
hand it could be that the Fearsome
pirate Servo and his scurvy Robo crew
found some way to call upon the Abyssal
Leviathan to Aid them in their quest for
Mutiny I think I like that explanation
better because it gives some
mythological feel to tintalus and makes
the relationship between it and Servo
seem kind of like the one between the
Kraken and Davey Jones what can I say I
love Pirates of the Caribbean and
tintalus is pretty cracking like you've
gotta admit but whether tintalus was
simply a mysterious mythological monster
of the deep from ancient times that was
called upon by scurvy Pirates or it was
created by demise is up to you to
believe of course but one other detail
I'll point out that could be nothing but
could also mean something is that
tintalus's English name you know
tentalis is extremely similar to
Tantalus which is a Greek mythological
figure one of Zeus's many children that
was famously punished by being made to
stand in a pool of water that he could
not drink out of with an apple hanging
from a tree above him that he could not
eat because it was just Out Of Reach
that's actually where our modern word
tantalize or tantalizing comes from how
that relates to tentalis I'm not sure
but do with that information what you
will who knows maybe tintalus wasn't
always an Abyssal sea monster but was
cursed into that Forum long ago as a
punishment moving on to the next segment
of the video it's time to talk about the
many bosses that were definitely created
or influenced by the dark powers of
demise and Co the most obvious ones
would be the stealthos enemies or the
more powerful stall Master variants
which are of course risen Undead
skeletal monsters that were at one point
Warriors in life they're also one of the
only monsters in the entire franchise
that has made an appearance in every
Zelda game I think I'm not sure I
scripted that off the top of my head
somebody watching fact check that for me
but I'm pretty sure they've been in
every Zelda game anyway their
explanation is the same as always which
is that they are corpses quickened Once
More by demise next up we've got the
main boss Caldera the pyroclastic fiend
from the Earth Temple you know that
Bolder looking living glob of lava that
uses a bunch of rock his arm fortunately
for us we've got a pretty direct
confirmation from girohim himself that
scaldera was more than likely a demon
created by girohim he knows about
scaldera he even introduces link to
scaldera who he calls his friend what a
hospitable guy I guess I'll have to
refer to scaldera as the pyroclastic
friend from now on next up we've got the
one the only the terrifying ancient
automaton kaloctos located deep within
the Ancient Cistern now besides girohim
or demise himself colloctos is
undoubtedly one of the most recognizable
bosses in all of Zelda history I mean
just look at this thing it's shiny it's
kinda creepy it's got six arms and wee
little eggs I mean what's not to love as
its name insinuates and in conjunction
with the Ancient Cistern within which it
is located colloctos is in fact ancient
and given that it was an automaton that
was ultimately tasked with guarding the
Chamber of the flame I'm pretty sure
hylia who apparently had an act for
making robots was the one to create both
the dungeon itself and colloctos that
being said koloctos might have actually
been a ancient machine ones much like
the LED models if it weren't for gear
rahim's interference and the corruption
of demise's malice that's right you
heard me
m-a-l-i-c-e the same stuff that's
swirling around in breath of the wild
that goes by the name Calamity again and
you may have heard of it I mean the
pieces add up it came from Ghirahim
which came from demise and it's a dark
purple goopy substance that possesses
and corrupts technology and it's
probably the same substance that's
dropped by the cursed the Goblins which
are also present in the dungeon which is
Monster malice referred to as an evil
Crystal when it crystallizes Faron also
states that the cistern used to not have
any monsters inside so this means that
once demise or maybe girohim got word of
Link obtaining the goddess sword girohim
took it upon himself to leak males into
the dungeon personally but what is this
a lore of the dungeons video
no no it's not so we're gonna move on
next up is the dark lizalfos which just
like their name sounds are the dark
versions of regular foes these dark Liz
olfos are two Liz alfos what cursed
vakoblins are tubacablins well kind of
because they don't look like zombies but
they can curse link just like cursed
mccoblin bites do they don't drop evil
crystals as loot but the fact that other
enemies in the game that can also
inflict curse like the cursed picoblins
or dark keys do drop evil crystals leads
me to believe that the ability to curse
at least in skyward's Sword comes
directly from being possessed by
demise's malice as proven by the evil
crystals so in a nutshell dark Liz alfos
are more than likely malice tainted
lizelfos next up but also in the same
dungeon that the dark little foes are
first encountered are the multiple
appearing lava hand monsters known as
magminosis and to be honest with you
there's literally nothing about their
origins in the game so logically I feel
that just like girohim was able to
create a living lava demon monster known
as Caldera the pyroclastic friend he
probably was also able to create these
living lava demon hand monsters who
knows maybe scaldera and the magminosis
are not only a cool band name but also
the result of malice being conjoined
with the lava of death Mountain I mean
Eldon volcano something we may be seeing
happen again in tears of the kingdom and
speaking of malice the final boss to
cover before covering the big baddies
themselves would be the easily
forgettable bilocyte which is the
parasite responsible for corrupting
levius or levias or however you
pronounce his name the wind fish and
also for causing his temporary insanity
bilocyte is malice plain and simple
seriously just look at this concept art
for levias dark reddish purple clouds
corruption sentient eyeballs yeah that
literally fits the bill for exactly what
malice is in breath of the wild the only
question I have is when did levias get
corrupted if he stayed flying up above
the cloud barrier then he should have
been largely unaffected by any of the
Badness happening on the surface right
well as we see in the Leviathan bones of
breath of the Wild and the ending
cutscene for Link's Awakening wind
fishes can definitely descend down to
the surface at will and in Skyward Sword
we even see leviath flying back up to
the sky from beneath the cloud Berry and
there's only one thing down there the
surface so it's possible that girohim
started been messing with the
Thunderdome turning it into a
Thunderdome and leviath then flew down
to the surface to check out what the
heck was going on and subsequently got
corrupted by malice somehow he never
actually sheds light on what happened
the personally I'm of the opinion that
it was in fact girohim's doing seriously
when in doubt blamed demise's Uber
powerful super demon running around the
world with the express purpose of
setting everything as out of order as
possible and what a masterful segue into
talking about the fabulous boy himself
in the final segment of this video but
right before we do explain Mr eyeshadow
I wanted to thank you for watching these
videos seriously I know it doesn't
really matter to the vast majority
watching right now but it means a lot to
me if this isn't the first one of these
videos of mine you've watched or if you
enjoy this one being your first one so
far by the way hi my name is Bandit nice
to meet you I wanted to ask if you would
be so kind as to consider subscribing to
the channel I know lots of you are
either rolling your eyes or looking to
fast forward the segment right now and
that's okay but for those of you still
listening I just wanted you to know that
for the first time I'm beginning to feel
like this channel could really grow like
really really grow especially with this
lore of the bosses series expanding into
other franchises and I can see that
eighty percent of my viewers are about
four out of every five people watching
my videos currently are actually not
subscribed to the channel to put that
into perspective if that were flipped
and it was actually 80 of you that are
subscribed then this channel would
literally be at over 1 million
subscribers since starting the lore of
the bosses series which is insane to
think about but anyway I won't take up
any more runtime talking about this once
again thank you so much for watching and
please consider subscribing to help grow
the channel and flip that statistic to
help get us to let's say three hundred
thousand dream big right and you can
always unsubscribe later if I lose my
touch and now back to girohim and really
it's kind of hard to explain girohim's
existence without also explaining
demises but in either case let's start
with what we know about girohim we know
that he's a Demon Lord being one of the
most powerful versions of monsters in
the entire franchise who proclaims
himself to be the lord of the surface
and that he was created by demise in
order to be an extension of his will and
carry on the battle against hylia no
matter how many years it might take
which is exactly parallel to five who
was created by hylia in order to be an
extension of her will and carry on the
battle against demise no matter how many
years that might take but more on the
parallelism between these two parties in
just a bit he's also very confident and
driven and cunning able to thwart even a
wish of the Triforce but none of that is
crucial information to be honest girihim
really isn't that hard to explain he was
created by demise he serves demise case
closed the real mystery is why is
everything regarding girohim and demise
strangely exactly parallel to hylia and
her partner well I'll tell you what I
think but forewarning we are entering
the major Theory zone of course you are
as always welcome to leave whatever you
personally would like to I'd like to
start off by saying that there are many
different theories about how demise came
from Laurel and stuff like that and it's
all really good stuff ultimately as far
as I can tell it comes down to the fact
that demise is said to have emerged from
a fissure or crack within the Earth and
his master sword AKA Ibrahim in sword
form has an inverted Triforce symbol in
the exact place where the highly a
master sword has an upright one the
fissure that he emerged from is similar
to the fissures that connect Laurel and
Hyrule in A Link Between Worlds and the
inverted Triforce symbol is seemingly
the same as the inverted Triforce symbol
also from low rule which was a land
destroyed long ago this theory
insinuates that that might even be the
entire reasoning for demise invading
Hyrule so that he could have hyrule's
Triforce instead like I said this is
actually a really good theory and really
great way of thinking but it does leave
a few things up to the imagination for
instance it doesn't explain where demise
came from as in literally where or
rather who he came from it also doesn't
explain his intentions as in why he
wants a Triforce in the first place or
why he hates you know good my theory
will explain both in the beginning the
goddesses created everything every ocean
Every Mountain Every Creature down to
every last blade of grass and this isn't
debatable this is canonical proven lore
that even has its own cut scenes in
Ocarina of Time in Twilight Princess and
once the goddesses were finished with
their creation they left the world and
at the point of their departure the
Triforce was made however that was not
all that was created now I'd like to ask
you something something that's very
philosophical but also a cold reality
given that the world of Hyrule was
created that would mean that nothing
existed before it right meaning light
and dark heat and cold up and down and
good and evil and all these contrasting
forces of the universe that give it form
did not exist yet when the world was
created all of these things came to
fruition out of the creation of contrast
because in each case one cannot exist
without the other light was created
therefore dark was subsequently created
as well heat was created therefore cold
was as well up was created therefore
down was as well and good was created
therefore evil must have been created as
well and this is the Crux of my theory
what if the concepts of Good and Evil
which must have been created along with
the creation of everything were actually
literally manifested in the beings known
as hylia the goddess and demise the
demon twin deities of Good and Evil to
govern the world and Define life and
progress think about it where else would
demise have come from if not from the
same origin of literally everything else
in the universe and given that
everything that is good in the entire
franchise somehow stems from hylia and
everything that's evil in the entire
franchise somehow stems from demise and
both of these individuals are
inexplicably all-powerful with permanent
Eternal effects on the world wouldn't it
make sense for both of them to literally
be the embodiments of Good and Evil
incarnate I mean the more you think
about it the more it actually makes
sense everything about them is perfectly
parallel to one another hylia defends
the Triforce demise pursues it hylia
created a master sword with a Triforce
facing Skyward demise created a master
sword with a Triforce facing towards the
Earth highly exists at the Edge of Time
demise has conquered time itself do you
see a pattern because it's actually
everywhere and we know the goddesses
themselves are morally neutral I mean
they have to be right plus we've seen
them time and time again make very
morally gray choices such as the repeat
heated choosing of Ganondorf to host the
Triforce of power or the flooding of
Hyrule player or the flooding of Hyrule
prior to Wind Waker you know not
everyone made it out alive of that one
mountaintops are only so big so in my
opinion this works perfectly because the
goddesses themselves are outside of our
ideologies of Good and Evil because they
created it but okay you're probably
thinking right about now yeah that's
logical and philosophical and everything
and it does explain exactly where demise
came from but what about his rage his
hatred that never perishes where did
that come from and that is a great
question because seriously what happened
to demise to make him so eternally
hateful of the goddesses in hylia well
here's a simple kind of paradoxical
answer for you what if he's simply
self-aware demise isn't stupid actually
quite the opposite he's brilliant and so
masterful a tactician that he
successfully plotted his own escape from
his imprisoned form before he was even
imprisoned by creating girohim so what
if demise is so hateful of the goddesses
because he knows why they created him
and he didn't ask to be made he didn't
ask for this life of pain and I know
that's a really dark concept but
seriously what if you found out one day
that you were created for the sole
purpose of being the Incarnation of evil
in the world you were never destined for
a nice or good or happy ending unlike
your twin hylia instead you had only
bitterness and defeat to look forward to
as ordained by your creators so you let
your anger at your own existence
overcome you and become your every
thought not knowing that in your blind
rage and Defiance of your creators and
your twin you were becoming exactly what
they had intended you would become
hatred itself an eternal curse of ungood
and a necessary Force to drive life into
death into life into death into life
again all in an eternal cycle because
without contrast we don't have color
without Darkness we don't have light and
without unnecessary evil we don't have
good and that is my explanation for why
demise or more specifically the bringer
of demise as is his real name in
Japanese was created I do hope you
enjoyed Max explanations and if you did
please consider leaving a like on the
video to get it spread around more and
hey subscribe if you haven't yet because
I in the future of the channel would
greatly appreciate it also you'd stick
around for a bunch of extremely cool
videos so just you wait huge thanks as
always to my Bandit crew of which I have
a few new names to announce say hi to
Aslan Jay Gabrielle Chris H Sebastian D
John Francois p o and W and raging
zekron who all joined up on patreon and
right here on YouTube seriously what a
turnout you guys are all amazing And
Take My Breath Away another reason I
keep making these videos and just gosh
darn it thank you that's all I've got in
this one so be sure to follow me on my
socials and I'll see you next time this
is Bandit signing out peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]